what i want to do in this video is come
up with a relationship between the area
of a triangle and that triangle's
circumscribed circle or circum circle so
before we even think about the circum
circle let's just think about the area
of the triangle so let's say the
triangle let's say that the triangle
looks something
like
let's say that it looks something like
that actually i don't want to make it
look isosceles so let me make it a
little
let bit
let's look at let's make it so it
doesn't arbit it doesn't look like any
particular type of triangle and let's
call this triangle capital a capital b
capital c that's the vertices and then
the lengths of the sides opposite
capital a is lower case a
lower case b over here and then
lowercase c now we know how to calculate
the area of this triangle if we know its
height so we can drop an altitude right
here
we can drop an altitude right here and
if this altitude has length h we know
that the area
we know that the area of a b c and
writing abc with the brackets around it
means the area of triangle abc
is equal to
one-half times the base which is
lowercase b
times the height
fair enough so we have an expression for
the area let's see if we can somehow
relate some of these things or the area
to the radius
of this triangle's circumscribed circle
and so a circumscribed circle is a
circle that passes through all of the
vertices of the triangle and every
triangle has a circumscribed circle so
let me try to draw it
this is the hard part right over here
so let me it might look something
might look something like this
that's fair enough that's close enough
to a circle i think you get the general
idea that is the circum circle for this
triangle or this triangle's
circumscribed
circumscribed circle let me label it
this is
this is that was a weird looking arrow
the circum circle
circum circle
for this triangle now let's think about
the center of that circum circle
sometimes referred to as the
circumcenter so it looks like it would
be sitting i don't know just eyeballing
it right on this little b here so that
is the circumcenter of the circle and
let's draw a diameter through that
circumcenter so let's draw a diameter
from vertex b
through that circumcenter so then
we go there and then we just keep
we just keep going over here and let's
call this point over here
let's call that point over there d
now let's create a triangle with
vertices a b and d so we can just draw
another line right over here and we have
triangle a b d
now we proved in the geometry playlist
and it's not actually a crazy proof at
all that any inscribed try any triangle
that's inscribed in a circle where one
of the sides of the triangle is the hype
is the is a diameter of the circle then
that is going to be a right triangle and
the angle that is going to be 90 degrees
is the angle opposite the diameter so
this is the right angle right here and
you could derive that pretty pretty
straightforward you have this arc here
you have
an arc here that is 180 degrees
that is 180 degrees because obviously
this is the diameter and it subtends
this inscribed angle and we've also
proved that an inscribed angle that's
subtended by an arc will be half of the
arc length this is this is a 180 degree
arc so this will be a 90 degree angle so
either way this is going to be 90
degrees over there
now the other thing that we see is we
have this arc right over here that i'm
drawing in magenta the arc that goes
from a to b
well that arc subtends two different
angles in our drawing it subtends this
angle right over here angle acb
it subtends that right over there but it
also subtends angle a d b that's why we
constructed it this way so it also
subtends this so these two angles are
going to be congruent they're both going
to have half the degree measure of this
arc over here because they're both
inscribed angles subtended by the same
exact arc now something interesting is
popping up we have two triangles here
we have triangle abd and triangle b
and triangle b i don't know we could
call this e and triangle b e c
they have two angles of their same they
have a right angle and they have this
magenta angle right angle in this
magenta angle so their third angle must
be the same
do it in yellow their third angle this
angle must be congruent to that angle so
they have three angles that are the same
they must be similar triangles or the
ratio between corresponding sides must
be the same
so we can use that information now to
relate the length of this side which is
really diameter it's two times the
radius to to the height of this smaller
triangle and we know relationship
between the height of the small triangle
and the area and we are essentially in
the home stretch so let's do that so
these are two similar triangles so we
know that the ratio
we know that the ratio of
c
that we know that the ratio of c
c to
this diameter right over here but what's
the length of the diameter the length of
the diameter is 2
times the radius this is a radius and
this is a radius right here we know that
the ratio of c
times
c to 2 times the radius is going to be
the same exact thing as the ratio of h
as the ratio of h and we want to make
sure we're using the same side to the
hypotenuse of that triangle to
the ratio of h to a and the way we
figured that out the way we figured out
we looked at corresponding sides c and
the hypotenuse are both
are both the sides adjacent to this
angle right over here so we have h and a
over here so c is to 2r as h is to a
or we could solve well we could do a lot
of things so we could one we could just
substitute we can solve for h over here
and then substitute this and substitute
an expression that has the area in for h
actually let's just do that so let's say
so if we use this first expression that
we have for the area we could we could
multiply both sides by 2
we can multiply both sides by 2 and
divide both sides by b
and divide both sides by b that cancels
with that that cancels with that we get
that h is equal to two times the area
over b so we can rewrite this little
relationship as c over two r
is equal to h which is two times
two times the area of our triangle 2
times our the area of our triangle over
b and then all of that is going to be
all of that is going to be over a
or we could rewrite this second part
right over here as 2 times the area
2 times the area over we're dividing by
b and then dividing by a that's just the
same thing as dividing by
dividing by a b and so we can ignore
this right here so we have c over 2 r is
equal to 2 times the area over a b
and now we can cross multiply we could
have a b times c i'll do a new color
just to ease the monotony a b times c
a b
times c
a b times c is going to be equal to
2 r times 2 abc so that's going to be 4
r
times the area of our triangle i just
cross multiplied this times this is
going to be equal to that times that and
we know that all cross multiplication is
is just multiplying both sides of the
equation by 2r
and multiplying both sides of the
equation by a b so we did that on the
left hand side we also have to do it on
the right hand side 2r
and a b obviously that cancels with that
that cancels with that so you get abc is
equal to 2r times 2abc or 4r times the
area of our triangle and now we're at
the home stretch we divide both sides of
this
you divide both sides of this by four
times the area
four times
four times the area and we're done this
cancels with that that cancels with that
and we have our relationship
the radius the radius of we could call
it the circum radius the radius of this
triangle circumscribed circle is equal
to the product of the sides of the
triangle divided by four times four
times the area
four times the area of the triangle
that's a pretty neat result